never tell me your the title for this
movie what's your number I always think
of my favorite Michael Jackson song
blood on the dance floor I was thinking
that maybe you'd want to be my date see
my sisters ready their parents for me
have my sister's ready I think so what's
your number stars on a ferris and Chris
Evans it's a romantic comedy but a woman
who decides to go and find all of her
exes and see if one of them fits maybe
one of them has changed over the years
or become a better person she enlists
the help of her neighbor Chris Evans to
help find these guys apparently he's
very good at finding people that's you
know his dad used to take him on
stakeouts or something I don't know and
you know we see we think they're gonna
go you know they're gonna start liking
each other and you know it's predictable
predictable or made at the comedy fair
ah however I enjoyed this movie I locked
myself out of my apartment you mind if I
use your phone when every guy you run
into seems to be on the run do you think
the woman coming out of your apartment
could have helped you with a bean
locked-out problem I look at it as
trying to avoid her feelings
I'm gonna be honest with you I'm not
gonna be the guy who's like yeah yeah
this movie was horrible and was terrible
and subscribe to me please I'm gonna be
honest with you I had fun with this
movie I enjoyed it I liked on Affairs a
lot and I thought she was hilarious and
adorable
I liked Chris Evans in the movie I
thought they had excellent chemistry I
thought they worked well together and I
laughed a lot there I said it I laughed
a lot of this movie I don't get why it's
getting so much hate you help me track
down my exes I'll help you escape yours
you got a deal what about Jerry Perry
he's a puppeteer so he's single you
should give me your number we should
catch up you know what I think I'm all
caught up
Oh guys it's not the say the movie is
without problems I mean it's predictable
it's
nothing new we've seen it all before the
finale has really strange odd moments
that you know would never happened and
you're just like look why don't you just
do it this way it'd be a lot easier but
if it's it that way it would take longer
and the movie would never end there was
also a few moments in the movie where I
was like come on seriously but then
characters would then address exactly
what I just said in my head and I was
like oh okay well at least you are aware
of it what about Simon Forester Halle
it's brilliant to see this is Colin but
he has to go now no I don't what
happened my Jackson was rusty and I went
full Borat slow girl then it's just kind
of what I needed to watch at the time I
just I felt like watching a fun silly
movie see I saw I don't know how she
doesn't recently that was a movie that
tried to empower women
but unfortunately made them look 100%
not like women I spoke with a lot of
women who saw that movie and did not
like it this movie it's similar to how
bridesmaids was where I just let women
just be women and you know like it was
just like yeah sure you can act like
guys if you want you can make fart jokes
if you want it didn't make women seem
like the cliche movie woman you know or
they're like perfect and have a huge job
at some company and have a family and
make chicken every night it portrayed
women as how a lot of women I know
actually are just just girls they're
just you know girls and I like that
about this movie and that's I'm gonna
give what's your number of B I don't get
the hate whatever
I enjoyed the film it was good how do
you know what you want you don't know
who you want
how'd you go to my sister's wedding
alone I'll go with you you would do that
good
sometimes you can't live life by the
numbers to figure it out as you go along
what's your number if you like this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck mine eyes please girls I
need a bigger girl demographic come on